tell us about your character how you got
off the pocket um I'd play cadence with
his younger kind of from the other side
of the tracks what I loved about her is
that you know she kind of has this this
strength about her and and kind of the
light in the film that's why I think I
was drawn to her train and did you do
sort of your own backstory on what
motivates her she comes from maybe a
rough part of town and why she is wishes
yeah I mean you know for me I come from
you know a very supportive family and
she didn't have that and so I kind of
had to to connect into something
different and and you know sheesh is the
exact opposite but you know loving
caring family but yet she's not defined
by that and
I think that's kind of what drives our
for an actress what is the best way for
a director to give you notes to give you
feedback is it to take you aside away
from the trim away from the other actors
how's the best way to go to know for me
I love a hands-on director and because
they know the character backwards and
forwards and just especially with ramin
it was such an incredible experience be
able to to talk with him and bring you
know this girl to life because he knew
you know how does it every detail about
about her and just me bring you know my
my aspects you know and him and just
kind of you know that brain is real
delight and pleasure well thank you guys
for you so much